LAURENCE MORONEY:
Hi, and welcome again
to Geocasts, where
we'll teach you
all about using Google
Maps to build better apps.
I'm Laurence, and
in this video, I'm
going to talk all about building
an interactive experience using
the Places API.
It's a simple game where you can
define three real-world places
and then have your
users go to them as part
of the overall narrative
of saving Alyssa here
from being trapped in
a parallel dimension.
In part one of this tutorial,
we identified and stored
three places using the
Places API, Firebase,
and some unique game codes.
So the next thing
to talk about is
how to use the Places API
to see if your user is
at the right place, so
that they can unlock
the next part of the story.
The Places API is designed
to make your apps stand
out with detailed information
about over 100 million places
around the world across a
wide range of categories.
And it uses the same
database as Google Maps.
We used this information in
part one of the tutorial.
But not only that,
the Places API
has location
detection, giving you
the ability to tell if you
are in the right place.
ALYSSA: That makes it easier.
I can just tell you to go to
a specific place, like, say,
the Seattle Space
Needle, instead
of dealing with latitude
and longitude or addresses.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's
right, and the Places API can
detect if the user is there.
ALYSSA: Well, of course
I'm there, silly!
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So let's take a look
at how you would build
the app to scan and detect
where you are.
ALYSSA: OK, I see
you are scanning
for the bridge between
our dimensions,
but you aren't close to it yet.
LAURENCE MORONEY: In
the previous video,
we saw how the user can
pick three real-world places
and save them to a Firebase
database using a code
to define them.
So if you want to play
the game, then you
start it with that
code, and you'll
be guided through
those three places
as part of the narrative.
But of course, the
game needs to know
if you are at that
place in order to unlock
the next part of the story.
So let's take a look at
the code to achieve this.
It uses the Place Detection
API's GetCurrentPlace call
to find the current location.
This requires the Access
Find Location permission
to be set in your app.
Remember, you can learn all
about permissions at this link.
Do note that this is
subject to limits.
So make sure you don't
call it too often.
You can learn more about
the usage limits here.
So, when building an
experience like this one,
instead of constantly
polling the device location
and calling the Places API
to get place information,
it's probably better for
you to do it on demand.
I.e., in this case Alyssa told
me to go to a specific place.
So when I think I'm
nearby, I can ping her
and she can tell me if
I'm close enough or not.
The call returns a place
likelihood buffer in a pending
result. A place
likelihood buffer
is a list of places near
your current location
and the likelihood that
you are at that place.
So for example, in
a dense city area,
there could be two places
next door to each other
which are recognized
by the Places API.
And if you're in
between the two,
the Places API will
return both of them,
as well as anything else nearby.
This will come with a likelihood
of which one you're in.
So all you have to do
is look at this list
and see if the place you
are looking for is on it,
and if the likelihood
that you were there
is above a reasonable
threshold-- say, 60%, or 0.6
in this case.
And then you could go on to
the next part of the game.
It's really that simple.
ALYSSA: If it were
that simple, I
wouldn't have been trapped
in this parallel dimension.
I guess I should have used the
Places API instead of the flux
capacitor.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Good idea.
Thanks for watching
this Geocast,
and if you want to learn
more about Google Maps,
check out the Google
Developers site,
and don't forget to hit
that Subscribe button.